[Music]
hello everyone this is Grandmaster
Victor michalebsky
um I'm gonna show you uh how to prepare
for the for your opponents
based on a few recent examples of my own
games
the first example is the last round of
the Maya open in Portugal
in which I faced a very strong American
Grandmaster leonic I wonder
I played with the white pieces
and prepared the following line
D4 Knight F6
C4 E6 Knight C3
in fact was prepared for both the nimso
Indian which he also played with Bishop
B4
and the line which occurred in the game
which is D5
C takes
Knight takes
E4
Knight takes B takes and C5
I could see that my opponent played this
line quite a lot
boss offline and online
and so I decided to prepare a
a good idea against the system
basically Black's idea behind the move
C5 is to play next CTX D4 then check on
B4
black castles quickly and then develops
his Queen side pieces
and so I thought I'll go for the line
with Rook B1
this way why it stops the idea of Bishop
B4 check
so the move makes a lot of sense
black played Bishop E7
which I expected
now Knight F3
and short Castle
this normal theoretical position which
accurate in the tournament practice
many many times
but I saw a
a recent idea which is not very popular
yet but extremely interesting
the idea of H4
in fact this move is getting popular in
many different openings
and also in this line it seems it seems
to be very interesting
so White's idea is straightforward white
wants to go H5 H6
in order to weaken Black's King side
and if after H5 black plays H6 which
happened in the game white brings his
Rook via H3 to G3
and creates a pretty strong attack on
the king said
so let's see what happened in that game
a Wonder played B6
so I continued with H5
allowing the move H6 is probably not the
best idea because then the pawn will be
very good on H6
and so black played H6
and now white plays Rook H3
as I mentioned the idea behind this move
is to play Rook G3 to pin the g-pawn and
then white will also have a set of
Bishop takes H6
so black plays King gauge shade
moving the Kink from the G file well in
advance
still Rook G3
and now C takes D4
and this exactly is a position I
expected before the game
because play of blacks plays rather
natural and logical
exchange on G4 is also rather typical
for this position
and in a couple of previous games white
answer is the move C takes D4 with
recapture with the c Pawn which is
definitely a good move
but I thought why not to try the direct
attack by means of Queen D2
and that's the line I prepared for the
game
one of White's ideas is to sacrifice The
Rook once again a very direct thread
then the queen gets to H6
and white May create a very strong
attack
in some lines
white can even place he takes D4 and
brings this Rook to the G file
so I thought it might be interesting
Queen D2 and now my opponent made a
mistake which is also very
understandable he played Rook to jid
so he wants to stop the idea of Rook
takes G7
by a recapture and whisk his own Rook
but the text has a very clear
disadvantage
they have seven Pawn is now unprotected
and why it can take an immediate
advantage of this fact
so let's see what would be better than
playing Rook Jade
and what they uh also looked at before
the game
one of uh one of better moves in this
position would be the move GTX C3
white x with the queen queen takes C3
and then if black plays Bishop F6 which
also looks kinda natural
in fact black yet sander a very strong
attack
E5
the bishop goes to E7
and now
Bishop takes H6
once again white sacrificing something
on the king side
black has to take back G takes H6 and
then Queen goes to E3
creating a direct threat of Checkmate in
one
so black has nothing better than to play
Bishop G5
oops sorry
let me get back to this position
so black has nothing better than Bishop
G5
if if we play skin gauge 7 instead white
has a very strong check from D3
forcing the king back
so
black played I mean black has to play
Bishop G5
and then simply Knight takes H takes
and Rook takes
and even though black stops the
immediate shots White's attack is
extremely strong
I can show you one of the possible ways
for black
for black to continue
F5
trying to open the seventh rank for
defense and then white can go Rook G6
a rook to F7
Rook D1 bringing another piece into
attack
Queen f8 and Rook to D6 and if you look
at this position even though uh White is
down a piece
but the blacks pieces on the queen side
are completely out of play
and very difficult to develop them for
instance if we go Knight A6
white plays Queen G5
did
black can try to stop that idea with
Bishop B7
but then Rook G takes E6
now the sixth rank is open for White's
Rooks
and the white is going to play Rook H6
next so black and try rook h7s and still
The Rook is going to H6
black finally brings his last piece into
play but it turns out to be too late
white can simply protect the phone Z5
Pawn with F4 Knight C5 Bishop C4
94 then just Rook takes Kink takes and a
nice Final Touch Bishop G check
so in case of Queen takes Jade black
gets checkmated on H6
and if the King goes to h8
Rook H6 check winning the queen and
obtaining a winning position
so all of this
could have happened if black played
Bishop F6 in this position
so this only defense after d takes C3
Queen takes C3 is the move E5
and even in this case ah White's attack
is pretty strong
so let's get back to the game now
so as we said black was afraid of Rook
takes G7 sacrifice and played Rook to
jid
avoiding the idea of Rook takes G7 but
as we said the F7
square is now weak
and I decided to take an immediate
advantage of this fact and played Knight
to E5
in fact white is already clearly better
and it's not so easy to get such a nice
position out of the opening against
26.50
uh rated player
right so so the opening line worked
really well in this game
I'll show you what happened in a few
moves
so my opponent played Queen E4 which was
also a mistake in fact
the only defense would be Queen a fade
but it's a little bit anti-intuitive to
put the queen on f8
when white can play Rook F3 the F Pawn
is blocked that means SF Pawn is pinned
their ideas is Knight G6 as well looks
extremely dangerous but in fact here
black still retains some chances
that's one of the possible continuations
here
now ah black cannot take the bishop in
view of Knight takes F7 check
and E5 opening the light squares for the
bishop or the queen
but in fact black can play Bishop takes
E5 sacrifice in the queen and staying in
the game
so that would be the best defense
but he played Queenie Queenie
which looks rather natural
so I decided to put even more pressure
on the F7 Pawn
and one of the key ideas is that if
black plays Bishop to F6
white can play Rook G6
a nice Rook sacrifice
in fact the move is a double attack on
F6 and H6
so if black takes a knight then Rook H6
leads to an immediate checkmate
and if instead of taking the Knight
black takes my Rook
then I can play Knight takes G6
key engage 7 and E5
and this way white opens the light
squares again the idea is to play Queen
E4
and if black stops the idea of Queen E4
by the way Queen E4 followed by Knight
f8 and queen H7 checkmate
so that's a deadly idea and so if black
is trying to stop it with Bishop B7 then
white plays e takes F6
threatening to play F6 F7
and in case of E5 the queen still gets
to this diagonal and
black is in trouble
and so my opponent decided to meet Queen
F4 with the move
F6
but also this move has a drawback now
the G6 square is weak
and so the Knight can get there
Knight G6 check
King Gage 7 and another important move
E5 not allowing black to play 6 C5
so black tried to block the diagonal
with the move
F5
and move like Bishop B7 doesn't really
help because y takes
Bishop takes and then Bishop to D3
with an extremely strong attack
so black played F5 and then suddenly uh
y changes the vector of the attack and
plays Queen to F3
and suddenly a black realizes that
zirukone8 is trapped
if black plays Knight C6
then after Knight takes E7 he loses a
piece
the Knight is pinned and after Queen E7
simply Queen takes C6
so it's already a lost position here on
move 18.
very surprising that right after the
opening you can get the winning position
against the against such a strong player
so
so the opening idea was extremely
important here
so now and I went on to win this game my
opponent found still uh
some ideas how to put some resistance in
this game but anyway I managed to win
the game and the tournament by the way
this was the last round game
so a winning this game was very
important
let's look at another example
which is in some way similar to this one
in this game
also a last round game
in the uh
in the tournament in in the open
tournament in Toronto
I played against
Ayan
feeding Master Kelly berda
uh with the white pieces again
started the game again with the move d4
the Knight goes to F6
C4
E6
Knight C3
Bishop to B4
I knew that my opponent is going to play
the nimso
and so I prepared this line with F3
D5
A3 Bishop takes C3 B takes C3 and C5
these are just the starting moves of
this system
y takes C takes D5 Knight takes D5 D
takes C5 and queen A5
all of this is the well-known Theory
E4
black plays Knight F6 that's one of the
possible Retreats of the night
taking on C3 is not a good idea because
of Queen D2 followed by Bishop B2
taken with the queen is just impossible
Envy of Bishop G2 The Rook is protected
and
black loses the Knight
so black played Knight F6 yes I said
there are also as a Retreats of the
night
white protects the C5 Pawn with Bishop E
Series that's more important that this
Pawn is more important than the
C3 Pawn
so now black castled
and the idea which I prepared is even uh
less popular than in the first game
but the move is the same H4
once again the idea is to create an
attack on the king Side by means of H5
H6 like in the previous game
and in fact first I saw this idea in in
the game of Anish giri who played it in
a Blitz game
and one very convincingly
so we're gonna see this game shortly
so uh blackplate Knight fd7
in both my game and Geary's game
by the way by the way there was another
game in the recent World Cup in which
white also won with this line with H4
so as you can see this idea of h4h5
exits in a different openings different
opening clients
and it's it might be very interesting
so once again white plays H5
and the ID is similar to play H6
so black played H6 and this time instead
of the maneuver Rook H3 Rook G3 like in
the first game
white plays G2 G4 and goes for the
direct attack
so the idea is to play G5 and after
black takes to go for H6
so my opponent played F6 in fact a very
reasonable move which I didn't expect
uh
during my preparation for the game
but let's see what happens if black
takes the pawn on C5
that's what happened in Gary's game
there is a question what stops black
from taking the pawn on C3 black can
take the pawn now but why just play skin
gift too and the problem is later he
will be unable to take the C5 Pawn
in view of Rook C1
so he'll have to waste even more time
removing the queen from C3 and time is
really important here because
black is completely undeveloped
and let's come back to giri's game in
which black played Knight takes C5
so white continued with G5
and after
Rook did
which looks very natural to bring the
Rook into play with the temple
white played Queen C2
H takes G5 and H6 opening sage file
blacks only attempt to keep the H file
closed
is G7 G6
but then white plays H7 check
the King goes to h8
white cannot play Bishop D4 right away
because the C Pawn is pinned
and so instead Anish played Knight to H3
a very nice move
the Knight is going to G5
and then eventually to F7
black tried to develop his Knight Knight
bd7 Knight takes G5 and protect the F7
Pawn With The Rook
from my fate
but then
white played therefore
preparing the move Bishop D4
the immediate Bishop D4 would be
answered by E5
that's why
white starts with the four
so black played F7 F6
and simply the Knight goes to F3
now black still has problems with
development at the very weak King the
game ended in just a few moves here
black played Queen to A4 and after
exchange of Queens
white go to the dark squares by means of
E5
black took
Knight X E5
the Knight is coming to G6 so it has to
be captured
and a nice intermediate move Bishop to
D4
so now the Knight is the bishop is
coming to E5
and White's attack is just decisive here
black tried to give up an exchange with
Rook F5
but why doesn't even take the Knight and
played
Bishop D3
a huge attack and
black just resigned so that was this was
played in the game
in a blitzki in the Blitz game giri
lasavik
earlier this year
so I I saw this game before my game and
so that might be a good idea to try
something similar
right so
yeah but my opponent thought here for a
while for a while and found an
interesting defense he played F7 F6
a very reasonable move which stops the
idea of G5
so I played Queen to B3
putting pressure on the E6 spawn
and then Knight to A6 a very strong move
if black plays Knight takes C5
winning back 65 Pawn
white has a strong move Queen B4
and then the game after Queen takes B4
is clearly in White's favor
white can take boss with a or C Pawn in
both cases it will be better for it
two strong Bishops pressure on A7 on
this position as well
also more space on the king side
so white has a clear advantage of this
case so black correctly played Knight A6
first
so now his idea is to play Knight D2 C5
and they will be unable to trade Queens
with Queen before
in this position I I was thinking for at
least half an hour
because it looks very dangerous to take
the pawn on E6 because the queen gets
under attack very soon
and the boss C3 and C5 pawns are under
attack
but I couldn't find anything better I
tried all different ideas here's
something like Bishop takes A6
and then black can take both ways in
fact black can take with the queen
and then the Knight is getting to E5 to
maybe Clyde squares
C4 is also weak
black can even take with the B Pawn
opening the B file for his rook and even
this idea might be pretty dangerous
no my opponent didn't really see that
game because he he was thinking for a
very long time before uh Finance this
idea of F6
so I I realized Bishop takes six six
wouldn't be good
if I allow Knight D2 to 90 takes C5
black is gonna get a nice position so I
should go for Queen takes E6 basically
Queen E6 check
and he played Kim Gage shade in fact
most of the time I was thinking about
the move King to H7
and it seems that this is a better
option in some lines it's important
that the king is not on the back Rank
and doesn't get under attack
for instance like in the line which
happened in the game let's say if I
Still Play Bishop D4
black plays Knight E5 with a discovered
attack
and say after the move Queen E7 Rook F7
the move Queen 8 is not a check
that's one of the reasons I thought the
Kink will be safer on H7
but he played King 2 h8
and now I had a very simple and strong
move at the same time King to F2
the reason is that Black's direct threat
as Queen takes C3
with a double attack on E1 and A1 and
this C5 Pawn is lost anyway so I'm I
don't need to protect this one
so what I have to do I have to deal with
the main thread of Queen takes C3 and
King F2 was the correct way to do so
and it turns out that White's chances
are higher in this position
instead I played Bishop D4
right so that might be a good idea to
put my Bishop on to protect the C3 Pawn
and put my Bishop onto this diagonal so
I may have a chance to play G5 at some
position and after H takes H6
opening up Black's King side
his reaction was correct Knight D takes
C5
the queen goes to E7
attacking zero corner f8
and now his only move Bishop takes G4 a
nice sacrifice
which I expected but I couldn't really
do much about it
so the point is that if I take with F
Pawn
blacks attack after rookette might be
decisive
extremely strong with my kink in the
center the E4 Pawn is falling
and so I prepared the move Bishop takes
A6 first
the point is that he cannot take back
with the queen since his Knight is
hanging
and I wanna Force the night back to A6
and then the Knight is not participating
in Zyrtec
so as soon as he takes my Bishop is a
knight I can take his Bishop on G4
in fact during the game I saw that he
had a strong option of Knight to B3
this looks like a very interesting move
which attacks boss A1 and D4
after he gets the bishop on the forza C3
Pawn will be also under attack
but in fact it turns out that Knight B3
is a mistake and black and white can
just play Queen to B4
Queen takes eight takes
blackwind Circle A1
but why take the B7 Pawn
Rook a bead
Bishop D5 this is her as a force line
the Knight goes to C2
King D2 Knight takes D4 black takes the
bishop on G4
Knight B5 and Knight E2
and even though white has only one Pawn
for the exchange
white White's position is much better
a very strong Bishop
the Knight is coming to the weak squares
and
that's very unpleasant for black
and my opponent played the correct move
again Knight takes A6 instead of going
to B3
now I took the bishop on G4
and the afro goes to E8 and in fact only
this move is a mistake
here my opponent had to come to eat with
the other look
Rook a to E8
and after I take with the queen he can
bring his Knight into attack with a
Tempo Knight to C5
it turns out in the raising
complications the position is rather
equal
obviously I didn't calculate all of
these lines that's already a computer
analysis after the game
and okay the position is still very
complicated
okay we will not go on
we'll just see what happened in the game
my opponent played Rook F28 instead
and then the queen went to F7
even though computer says Queen takes B7
is the best move
but in the uh in the game I thought that
giving up the B file is extremely
dangerous
also blackthrough can get to B2
and even though computer shows there is
a defense in this position I believe my
move Queen F7 is more practical
so black two crook takes E4
the King goes to F2
and now the decisive mistake from black
the move which is rather natural Rook a
to E8
black doubles his Rooks on the e-file it
looks very it looks like a very logical
idea but in fact the only uh
the only move in this position is
the greedy Rook takes G4
now I can take Z file on the control
with Queen E6 but black plays Rook F4
check
Knight F3 brings his Knight with the
tempo again
Queen E7 Knight D3
Queen F5
again a very interesting position here
Knight H4 Queen takes H5
now Rook a to G1 creating a threat of
Checkmate in one and a threat of Knight
G6 but black can play Rook 8 opinion
my queen
still Knight G6 check Queen takes Rook
takes Rook takes C7 and King takes D3
is the bishop versus three Pawns which
gives white some Advantage but black
retains droy's chances in this position
instead he played Rook a to eat
and this allowed me to develop the
Knight Knight F3
hi Christopher rookie to check
and King to G1
this is probably the safest my idea is
to bring this Rook to F1 and if I need
to cover the G3 Square I have the other
look which can come to H3
he played Queen B5
zuru came to F1
there is also an interest in uh
direct win with Bishop takes F6
G takes Queen takes
the King goes to H7
Queen G6 check
Queen takes H6 check
King Jade Queen G6 check
from F6 King cheat and H6
and
white threads are decisive
instead I play through F1
which is also enough
to win the game
black try to Rook a to E4 in order to
bring the Rook to G4
white Place Rook
H4
simply protecting the pawn and now my
idea is to play G4 G5 next move
to finally get to black skin and after
G5 I'll be straightening into play Queen
a fade follow followed by G6 if he
captures the pawn I can push H6
and capturing with the F Pawn is
impossible
as it opens my dark squared bishop and
queen G7 will be checkmate
so after Rook H4 he played Queen C6
G5
white can also start with Queen f8 check
and only ng5 but in both cases White's
position is winning
now he took H takes G5
and after the move H6 had to resign
so as you can see the idea for H4 also
allowed me to win again again
and uh
it's very important to know this type of
ideas in the opening
so this
these two examples
show importance of this idea of h4h5 in
many different lines
the idea allowed me to win two last
rounds in the last two tournaments
so that's that's very important
okay let's go on and see another example
this example is again from a tournament
in Portugal
which I played right before the Canadian
tournament
my opponent my opponent was the
international master
Brower fronts
so he played E4 E5
Knight F3
Knight C6 and D4
that's one of the possible openings
which I expected in this game
so it takes D4 Knight takes D4
Knight F6
Knight takes C6 B takes C6 E5
all of this is well known Siri
black pins E5 Pawn
this queen E7
white plays Queen E2 the Knight goes to
D5
C2 C4
Bishop to A6
and here I expected mainly his move
Knight D2 which he played in most of his
previous games
but I also briefly looked at the move B3
which is in fact the main line
and the I'm pretty sure that he also
looked at my games in this system and I
mainly played here here is the move G7
G6 which is also the main line
and this may lead to a
easier a very complicated position after
Bishop A3
then Bishop B2 a lot of complications
here
and and so on
for instance this position accurate in
the recent game Karana vesely so and we
can see this earliest this year
and another option
for white after G6 is the move G3
and this one leads to an interest in
theoretical end game
this type of end game
it can also occur if black castles long
ing
so this is considered to be roughly
equal uh theoretical end game
but in this game I decided to surprise
my opponent in and play after B3
the move Queen to H4
the idea behind this move is very direct
white black wants to play Queen D4
and after Bishop to B2 Bishop B4
and black and white has serious problems
for instance if white plays G3 this may
happen
and white loses the game right away
so white played A3 which is the main
move here
white is just covering the B4 square and
so black doesn't have Bishop B4 check
anymore and then the idea of Queen D4
also makes no sense
white can simply answer Queen D4 is
Bishop to B2
and what I prepared at home I thought
that in case he goes for the line with
B3 I'll play Queen H4 and after the move
phase three I'll go for Knight to F4
and Factor as a reasonable line for
black
white plays Queen E4
and then Knight to G6
and somehow this idea took my opponent
of guard
he started sinking and making some
mistakes
so uh
the main move in this position is just
taking the queen on H4
black takes back with the Knight
then Knight to D2
black plays Bishop B7 with the idea of
pushing the C Pawn to C5 and putting
pressure on on the long diagonal on the
G2 Pawn
so white played G2 G3
black
played C5 in this position
and now there are two possible ways of
playing one of them is an exchange
sacrifice
with G takes H4 and then an attempt to
trap the bishop on H1
with the move FC but it turns out that
black is still doing fine here
after Bishop B7
King F2 and Rook to beat a very nice
move the idea is to meet
the move King G1 with Bishop takes F3
Knight takes F3 and Rook takes B3
so it's better to play Rook B1
then black can just play A5
preparing the move A4 as well
so white can play for then Bishop takes
King G1
the bishop gets trapped on H1 but uh
black still gets some counter Play
Bishop G5 King takes H1 black castles
and it turns out that
black creates counter plane this
position and
and the chances are probably roughly
equal
so that's one of the ways for a white to
play this position
instead of the move GTX H4
white can also try Rook G1 but then
black simply goes Knight F5
and brings the Knight to D4
lone cast link
black and play H5
King B1 A5 and the black has a good
position here
so all of this could have happened if
white took on H4
but instead he decided to keep Queens on
the board and played Queen to E3
it may look like a reasonable idea
because my queen on H4 gets under attack
very soon
and so my next move is rather logical
C6 C5 so now in case of G2 j3 I can play
Queen D4
for instance G3 Queen D4
after exchange on D4 Z5 Pawn is hanging
so white has to play F4 protecting that
pawn
and then I play C7 C5 I mean First
bishop B7 sorry
A5 and eventually C5 protecting the D4
pawn and black gets a good position
so
uh
he he played Bishop B2 instead of G3
taking the default Square under control
and now he's ready to play G3 on the
very next move
and I realized my best move would be
just playing Queen F4
and after exchange of Queens
white plays G3 I can come back to E6
once again towards the nice Square on D4
and Black's position is fine here
white can also start with the move Rook
G1
and once again black will play 96 Bishop
B7
and this position is fine
but during the game I thought that I can
try a different idea
I played Bishop B7
which is in fact slightly inaccurate
from the other hand it looks very
natural to put the bishop on this
diagonal
so uh now in case of the move G3
black and play Queen to E4
I have to admit that during the game
I had the wrong idea in mind I was
thinking about playing Queen to H6
allowing doubling of my pawns on the H
file and after Rook G1 Rook Jade the
point is that now I can bring my knight
to H4
maybe to F4 Sometimes using the pin on
the G file
but in according to computer white is
just better in this position
something like this may happen and
this position is better for weight
but after G3 I can also play Queen E4
and after exchange of Queens
Rook G1 black and play Bishop C2
attacking the B3 pawn and after Knight
D2 Rook to beat
once again putting pressure on B3
and so basically white needed to play
like this
to play G3 in this position
with maybe slightly better chances
instead he played Knight to D2 and an
accurate move
which I answered with a long castling
once again Queen F4 is a
very good alternative
which I also decided to avoid
so long cast link
Knight F3
and finally Queen F4
so now when I when I am forced to play
Queen F4 I am playing this move but the
White's problem is that after exchange
of Queen son F4
the G2 Pawn also gets under attack I may
play Bishop takes F3 in some position
creating a weak pawns on the king's side
and so after the move Queen F4
white already has to be precise not to
get in trouble
and what he did was a big mistake he
played Knight to G5
his idea is very obvious he wants to
trade queens and get my F7 Pawn
and in fact I consider it this idea and
saw that I can just sacrifice a pawn
and he will waste a lot of time with his
Knight
and it will be very dangerous for black
instead of the move Knight G5 the
correct way of playing would be
surprisingly the move h2h4
and then after I take one F3 G takes F3
white is threatening with the move H5
which would force me to take on E3 which
I don't want to do
so it's important to play rookie at
first
now in case of H5
I can even play Knight takes E5 and
after the capture on F4 I have this
double check and I get back the queen
white can cast along
and then I can just take only three and
take on E5
white plays Bishop H3 putting pressure
on my D7 Pawn
and then I can play Bishop to D6
F4 and Knight to F3
attacking these three Pawn
and black is doing fine in this position
nevertheless
White had to play H4
this will be magic patterns on what he
played in the game
he played the move Knight to G5
which I answered with Rook to eat
now the E5 Pawn is under attack
and so white has to trade Queens
and take the F7 Pawn
and then simply Rook G
white one upon but he wasted at least
two moves and also his Knight on F7
finds itself in some Danger
I am about to traps this Knight
and if if he comes back with this Knight
Knight G5 then I can play H6
Knight F3
the simple Bishop takes F3 G takes F3
and Bishop D6
black wins back Z5 Pawn
exchanges the dark squared Bishops the
bishop on F1 will be extremely weak
also the pawn structure on the king side
is very bad and black has a clear
advantage in this line
so uh
in fact after Rook Jade Black's chances
are already much higher but Black's best
defense would be against the move H4
and this time it's not that surprising
because black has a threat of G5
the point of G5 is to prevent white from
bringing the Knight back
and that's why it was necessary to play
H4
black can play H6
still stopping the night from getting to
G5
but it turns out it's not so easy to
trap the Knight now
white can play King to D2
if I play a move like rookie 7
white can play six and then the Knight
escapes from E5
so black needs to play 96 first to stop
this idea and prepare the move Rook E7
but then white has another defensive
idea Bishop to D3
preparing the move Bishop to H7 trapping
my Rook on cheat
so I need to play G6 to stop this ID and
then h4h5
another point of the move h2h4
black takes the pawn G takes H5 Rook
takes and now black takes the G2 Pawn
Rook F1
Bishop G7 white White's position is
still worse but that would be much
better than what happened in the game
and in the game he played Rook to G1
protecting the G2 Pawn moving The Rook
away from this diagonal
but the main problem here is the move G7
G5
so now the Knight gets stuck on F7
White Castles
and then just a simple move Knight F4 to
E6
once again if I play rookie 7 first
white can play 6 and escape with the
Knight
so that's why it's important to block
the E Pawn and now rookie 7 is a big
thread
during the game I saw that Black's
whites only defense in this position is
Bishop to D3
and then if I play rookie 7 he can try
Bishop takes H7
attacking my Rook on Jade
I can play Rook G7 and it may seem that
why just loses a piece but in in fact he
has a nice trick Knight D6 check
if I move my king aways and he simply
takes the bishop and escapes with his
Bishop
and if I takes he takes D6 y takes
attacking both of my Rooks
Rook takes H7
D takes E7
Bishop takes E7
F3 Rook takes H2 black still has a clear
advantage in this position but even
easier probably after the move Bishop D3
is to play H6 first
savings is 4 and only then going for a
rook E7
and here uh black should be able to win
without big problems
nevertheless white should have tried to
play Bishop D3
that would be the last chance in this
game instead he played
F2 F4
in order to meet my move Rook E7 with F5
followed by A6 and once again the Knight
can escape
but I can simply take this spawn on F4
with GTX F4
rookie 7 is again a big threat
so he tried to protect the Knight by
means of Bishop H5
zero goes to E7 attack in the night
Bishop H5
and now
the very simple Rook takes G2
okay I cannot really win the night yet
but what I can do I can get the G2 Pawn
now black is up a pawn and the F Pawn is
also extremely dangerous and it will go
forward very soon
now uh why try this trick with Knight D6
C takes it takes I played Rook e to G7
so Bishop takes Bishop takes black
obtains two minor pieces
versus Rook
very strong Bishops on B7 and G7 as
strong past Pawn
and basically whites is just hopeless in
this position
he played a couple of moves Rook G2
Bishop G2 King D2 F3 and realize that he
cannot even stop advance of the F Pawn
and so he resigned
so uh once again a good opening
preparation allowed me to get a nice
position out of the opening
what is also important to take your
opponent out of book
and eventually wins a game
so I believe this will be good for today
I want to thank everyone for watching
and I'll see you all very soon
[Music]